-Welcome back, everybody!
Welcome back!
I'm so happy you're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate you.
Thank you so much.
I love this time of year.
Fall is in full swing.
The weather is getting chilly,
which means
it's a great time
to snuggle up with a good book.
And I don't want
you guys reading any bad books.
So to help you out,
I'm going to show you
some books that
you should avoid at all costs.
That's right -- it's
time for my latest installment
of my "Do Not Read List."
Here we go.
-♪ Do not read ♪
♪ Do not read ♪
♪ Do not read these books ♪
♪ These books ♪
-Now, before we start,
I just want you all to know
that every book that I'm about
to show you is 100% real.
These are actual books.
You can find them on Amazon
or check them out
at your local library.
They are real.
And don't vote on these.
-Aw.
-These are real books, yeah.
And these are -- Yeah.
So, I want to show you
what's on my "Do Not Read List."
This first one
is a children's book.
-Oh!
-From the '70s, right?
This is very cool.
This one's called "I Want to be
a Service Station Attendant."
What child doesn't want to be
a service-station attendant?
So, in this story,
the dad gets a flat tire,
and they pull into
a gas-station attendant
and they meet
this guy named Jim.
And then Jim says,
"It's going to take some time."
And the dad says to his son,
"Chuck, do you want to go
across the street
and have a hamburger?"
And the son says,
"If you don't mind, Dad,
I'd like to stay here
and watch Jim."
"Dad nodded his head.
'Alright, fine.
I'll see you both
in a little while.'"
Take care.
You take care of my kid.
-Yeah.
-I'll leave my -- I'm going
to go get that hamburger."
Parenting -- parenting
was different in the '70s.
-Like "Sling Blade."
-It was different in the '70s.
"Yeah, just hang out
with that dude."
Oh, check out
this book right here, okay?
This is a romance book.
-Ooh! I love romance.
-Yeah. This is called
"Will You Give My Mommy a Baby?"
-Oh!
Oh! Oh, wow!
-By Carla Cassidy.
That's kind of a weird title.
Maybe the art
clears things up down here.
Does it clear anything up?
No, that's basically saying
what it is, yeah.
Wild.
-Whoa! somebody pitched a tent.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe it's that
gas-station attendant.
-You think it's Jim?
-Jim, yeah.
This next one is a D.I.Y. book.
-Oh, love it.
-Right?
Everyone loves a do it yourself.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this one right here.
There you go.
-You can't say that on TV.
-No, it's a "T" -- "Tucked."
-Oh, "T"!
My bad.
-You thought --
-I thought it was
a different letter.
-No, it was not, no.
-Whew!
-"Tucked --"
It's a quilting book.
-Oh, "T" -- tucked, tucked.
-It's a quilting book called...
-"Tucked Up in Bed," yeah.
-"Tucked Up in Bed."
There's a photo of a couple.
But zoom in on this cover.
Look -- it's like the woman is
laying next to a corpse almost.
-Whoa! Dude, that's tucked up.
-Yeah, that actually is.
That's pretty tucked up.
Yeah, I agree.
This next book
is a book about hairstyles.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love those books.
It's a -- It's called
"Milady's for Men Only."
-Mm!
-Already confusing.
-Milady's.
-Milady's, yeah.
But this is the thing
that kind of intrigued me.
I like this.
First of all, I like
this guy's pose right here
with the glasses.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, hey!
-Wow!
-But this is --
It's called spot perming.
Anyone know about hair?
Spot perming?
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
Well, here's the before.
This right here,
if you can zoom in.
That's before.
And here's the after.
He's basically just -- He just
faced a different direction.
-Yeah.
-That's the before and after.
Why mess with perfection?
-Yeah.
-This next book -- I love this.
It's called
"Disguise Techniques."
Yep. And it says,
"Nothing more to disguise
than putting on a costume."
So, let's see a costume,
the disguise techniques
they tell you here.
Alright, so,
this is really good.
This is an illustration
to help you out here.
This is a real book.
Look at the bottom one first.
This is normal people just
waiting for at bus stop, right?
Once you put on
a little disguise,
no one will even notice
that you're at the bus stop.
No one will even notice.
-No.
"What's that?"
"Nothing."
-Nothing.
It's a clown next to a hippie.
-Next to a flapper.
Yeah, nobody knows nothing.
-A flapper.
People are just
waiting for a bus.
-Yeah.
-What's the problem?
"What are you talking about?"
"I don't notice anything, yeah.
Why would my eye go there?"
-My eye would not go there.
-No, it would go right past it.
-Yeah, right to the bus, yeah.
-Yep. Right on the bus.
-Yeah, no, those people
waiting for the bus --
"What's going on?
I'm getting a little --
But now it's a clown.
And now I get it."
This -- We're down to
our last book here.
This is called
"Religion, Philosophy and Fun."
Can we see the author?
Looks like he's
having a blast right there.
There he is -- Bud Robinson.
That's all we have for
"Do Not Read."
If you have a book you think
should be on our list,
send it to
donotread@tonightshow.com.